may the fourth be with you ladies and
gentlemen it is 5
45 in the morning we just got our moon
night episode 6 reaction up
and now it's time for the obi-wan
trailer can't wait to see it leave a
like if you can use the force to leave a
like and yeah subscribe and click that
notification bell because you best bet
we're gonna be covering this show right
here on the chanel if you haven't seen
our reaction to the first trailer that's
also up here on the channel let's get
into action people
[Music]
they're coming
stay hidden
great shot of him
but we will not survive
[Music]
leave us alone when the time comes he
must be trained
like you trained his father
who ouch
uncle owen you still want kenobi
he's gone
[Music]
maybe you've been looking in the wrong
places
i want every lowlife and bounty hunter
to squeeze him
like john wick yeah absolutely
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
want but it would be cool you got it you
want to maybe want us to want to want to
see him you know what i mean these are
good trailers man there are shots with
the the river character especially when
she's like you can't run ob1 that
straight remind me out of uh the
inquisitor man blink on her name the the
one from uh the jedi fallen order the
prologue to that video game always nice
to be reminded of that video game at any
given moment just popping into my mind
right now there's something i believe it
was ryanairy from screen crush that
beautiful beat who pointed this out how
there was a line in a new hope vader
says like the last time i felt a tremor
in the force was when he sensed his old
master obviously being obi-wan kenobi
the reason i'm bringing that up is
because i've seen you know a good amount
of people because a lot of people are
very much excited to see hayden
christiansen don the suit of darth vader
once more and square off with obi-wan
again however i know there was that
other camp that is often like ah wasn't
that fight on mustafar supposed to be
their last big fight doesn't that kind
of undermine some of the context from
the moosa fire fight to the new hope
fight he says last night i felt the
tremor in the force in a new hope so
that could be in reference to the fight
that is actually going to take place in
this specific series so i'm excited to
see that unfold i'm just i'm just
excited to see you know you and mcgregor
return and of course to see hayden
christensen get a second shot because i
feel like more people have come around
to him i remember the backlash that
hayden christensen would get and i feel
like a lot more people have come around
to his performance i'm excited to see if
he can you know just get it and get an
opportunity to leave kind of a good
impression for audiences and for himself
too to feel that way walking away from
it all i like that they're still keeping
some kind of mystery around how and and
what shape exactly hayden christensen is
gonna show up i like that anticipation
factor getting a couple glimpses of
darth vader's suit and the bionic arm
and stuff like that i'm really excited
to see what they make of that because i
think they have an interesting and
unique opportunity here and the fact
that you have something that's both
prequel and sequel at the same time
you're filling in a middle chapter that
there's certainly lore for but we
haven't seen play out this way while i
could imagine a scenario in which yeah
they have to be very careful in how they
perhaps contextualize that tremor in the
force if that's what they're going to
try and do i feel like there is enough
here that they could make something very
meaningful especially the way they're
building this is like a six episode
event rather than just like oh it's
another one of our series or something
like that like something about this
feels a little separate and a little
more special in a way from out here and
obviously obi-wan is you know one of the
most iconic characters so i feel like
you have that really great sense of
honoring his portrayal of the character
and then yeah giving hayden christiansen
the chance to come back and to put a
fresh stamp on it under you know perhaps
some slightly different supervision
there are certain aspects of the
prequels that have been very detrimental
to the people involved so to see him get
to have this chance to come back and
really again go toe-to-toe hopefully
with obi-wan even if the whole show
isn't necessarily about that you know
that the presence of the two of them is
gonna be really significant together so
that's just something super exciting you
know you've got these sort of cd
obviously there's tons of cyberpunk
aesthetic throughout star wars but these
yeah neon lit cities that do have that
john wick vibe to it like it looks like
it's going to be a sort of rough and
tumble outlawish sort of show but
something different altogether than a
mandalorian type thing well yeah when i
was saying john wick i meant more in the
sense of how there's going to be more
than the inquisitors going after him
it's going to be like all they're trying
to get all the bounty hunters to go hunt
him down specifically so it's getting
that vibe of like john wick chapter two
and three where everyone's going after
him and the action does feel a lot more
there's like that handheld effect it
feels more akin to the action that we
kind of got in rogue one but we're gonna
get some lightsaber fights so i think
it's gonna be even cooler just when you
throw that kind of fighting style into
the series well i really appreciate it
here what is gonna be like a big
emotional conflict for the series which
is uncle owen and uh obi-wan i don't
know what is left cannon and what isn't
left canon anymore these days and no
they come to like comics and such uncle
owen gets to the point he's already at
this point but we will see most likely a
point where obi-wan decides to like move
far away from them where he's like still
trying to keep himself involved and look
over luke skywalker but he'll have to
reach a point and it seems like this
series will end at a moment where
obi-wan will eventually go you know i
actually agree with uncle owen even
though i know he doesn't like me but i
actually do get his point and i do have
to stay far away because after all these
events that have happened that takes
place in this series he does have to
distance himself but not stay too far
away you know obviously stays on
tattooing i like dealing with that
central conflict of watching that
decision be made where it seems like
instead of it just being uncle owen was
the one
who pushed him away obi-wan himself will
probably get to a point where he
realizes he has to distance himself even
more because that shot like at the
beginning with the binoculars and
watching luke skywalker seems like he's
probably
living in a cave pretty close by so he
can keep a watchful eye on him
ultimately he's endangering them more by
having the presence of the force that
obi-wan carries with him
that probably attracts like the
inquisitors like seeing camille here
it's a river character getting vibes
that she will turn good maybe not turn
good but like in the end make some
sacrifice you know at the last minute
or like some type of element there where
she goes against the inquisitors in the
end i'm excited to see the grand
inquisitor be in live action i've always
liked the look and i especially like the
walking shot there the fifth brother
want to see more of him if you watch
rebels obviously you'll be pretty
excited for fifth brother i have a lot
of faith in it this looks purely
cinematic in every single way guys
what'd you think about the trailer leave
your thoughts down below you can
subscribe click that bell leave a like
last but not least
i want to shout out my man david gandy i
wanted to apologize we have two boxes
here that i believe are from you that
have yet to be unboxed i am sorry in a
lot of ways i feel like you are our obi
one more i don't want to say elderly but
more our senior in a lot of ways our
great great great grandpa but i will not
use the word elderly our old man who is
also a wanderer a man of the martial
arts as well so you are in a lot of ways
our obi-wan looking out for us and
watching over us and i really appreciate
that about you obviously we have not
shown our gratitude by unboxing said
amazing gifts from you i promise we will
do that in about six to eight months
when we do it you will be
very much rewarded
with a great 20 second video of us
opening and looking and going thanks and
i know that's all you need
is half a smile
[Music]